Cuál fue el aporte de Eve de bonafini a
la lucha por los derechos humanos y
contra la desaparición en Argentina
Bueno
buenas tardes Muchas gracias por la
invitación a participar del programa
sin duda ha sido todavía es una figura
emblemática en esa lucha emprendida
durante la dictadura por familiares por
las madres abuelas y otros familiares de
desaparecidos para saber dónde estaban
sus parientes desde entonces se enfrentó
una cantidad innumerable de situaciones
complejas de mucha violencia de mucha
soledad y tuvo la capacidad junto a sus
compañeras las otras madres de
constituir un movimiento que se volvió
emblemático escala global por la lucha
por los Derechos Humanos
bien Qué va a pasar ahora con la
sucesión Madres de Plaza de Mayo que al
día de hoy siguen pidiendo justicia
bueno la lucha de las madres continuará
se prevé que las cenizas debes serán
esparcidas en la Plaza de Mayo como un
símbolo de que ella queda en la plaza
Aquel lugar frente a la casa rosada la
sede del gobierno argentino donde las
madres comenzaron sus rondas para pedir
por sus parientes para demandarnos saber
la verdad a la dictadura militar
encabezada por Jorge Rafael Videla y
luego lo continuaron haciendo como un
símbolo de una lucha que al igual que la
desaparición forzada ese crimen continuo
no no se detiene continúa a lo largo del
tiempo así que es probable que lo más
probable es que las más el resto de sus
compañeras las madres ya también
ancianas en continúan hasta el resto de
sus días dando vueltas dando las rondas
en la Plaza de Mayo los jueves a las
3:30 de la tarde claro señor crecer Ever
era muy cercana a varios líderes
latinoamericanos de izquierda por
ejemplo Rafael correa de Ecuador y Evo
Morales en que nos dice esto sobre la
figura de Eve no solo en Argentina sino
en América Latina
fue una figura que trascendió los
límites nacionales efectivamente como
señalas tuvo diálogo amistad y alianzas
políticas con numerosos líderes de
América Latina y también fue recibida Y
logró hacerse conocida en Europa dura
especialmente durante las dictaduras
durante la dictadura militar y nos habla
de una mujer aguerrida valiente que
supo enfrentar una dictadura que entre
otras políticas de seguridad nacional
implementó la desaparición forzada de
personas y que a la vez más allá del
enfrentamiento con esa dictadura tenía
un compromiso cierto con la búsqueda de
la justicia social con la búsqueda de
terminar con las desigualdad que es un
rasgo de saliente en América Latina de
la estructura social del continente su
Alianza con líderes que publican
políticas de
de inclusión y de mejoras en la calidad
de vida amplio sectores de la población
este sin duda habla de esa de esa
Alianza Y de esa idea que ella también
tenía junto con la demanda de verdad
justicia por los crímenes de la
dictadura